obviously on gutfeld
the most important question i have to
ask you is how about my ratings your
ratings are fabulous i just said you're
now the king of late nights
i mean you're beating some very
untalented people to be honest with you
so i'm not so sure how great that is but
they are so bad and it's about time
somebody came in and you're really
beating a badly great i feel kind of
guilty about it because i feel like i'm
beating up unarmed people well they're
not very talented you are so
congratulations i'm mildly talented
they're just untalented well and you're
very different yes i am very different
that is true
well hold on
sure whatever clap away
well if that's not emmy award-winning
stuff i don't know what is but maybe if
i sent contagious people to nursing
homes and then grab my co-workers asses
i'd have a chance
but i won't
but the fun hasn't stopped just yet
because it is time
for now the meeting of the mines
part three
we are now into part three of the
greatest presidential interview in the
history of presidential interviews
that's not funny
warning this interview is so powerful it
may change forever the way you look at
the world and especially me
but before we do that
greg seven jokes
envisioned like greg brady playing the
organ in that thing you know upstairs
and when he gets the attic but anyway
this afternoon president biden unveiled
his six-pronged plan to fight kovid it
was originally called a six step plan
but joe's not good with steps
fiden also prioritized getting kids back
into school
where they're easier to sniff
biden is also preparing to sue texas
over the new anti-abortion laws
that's right before heading to mass to
receive communion
you know because he's catholic
and they're
pro-life and
he
wants unborn children to die
you see the connection meanwhile
the taliban is expected to continue
their ban on music
which means afghans can only listen to
maroon 5.
turn the laugh track on
in other news congressman adam schiff
urged facebook to address the spread of
covent 19 vaccine misinformation on
social media and the company sprung into
action instantly deleting the account of
anthony fauci
yesterday a protester threw an egg at
gubernatorial candidate larry elder the
egging confirmed two things we already
knew about liberals one they hate black
republicans and two they throw like a
girl
i'm told that the deadly egg itself was
never recovered but detectives did find
several shell fragments
you don't have to laugh
and that's your seven jokes
and now
time for part three with our 45th
president donald trump take it away i've
got to ask you about uh hunter biden's
new profession have you seen any of his
paintings no i haven't seen him i've
seen uh i guess some newspaper shots of
them could you imagine if that was uh
don jr has decided to go into painting
while he's never painted before he wants
500 000 a shot and you know what they
don't even go after him no you and he
paints with his straw which is a new use
for a straw for him
when i heard that one i said oh this one
will never this one even the fake news
media will not allow
he's selling these paintings
yeah if my kids ever did that
they could they could do good things yes
i have a son raised 20 million dollars
for saint jude's and it was under two
years of investigation and he got
nothing out of it nothing
two years of investigation he raised 20
million i got the most beautiful letter
from the head of saint jude's that this
young man i won't even say which one of
my kids because why should i be great if
don jr or eric started selling sketches
and giving the money to like drug
addiction programs you know just like
some really primitive sketches before
before hunter ever sells a painting well
and this was during you know if if you
go during the presidency to do this okay
yeah but i think the paintings are the
least of it yeah you know that oh you
mentioned pain that's the least well
there's the gun violations and
well there's a load of other things you
know what we had a much softer justice
department and
uh let's say that they didn't like doing
that and i understand that too i don't
want to see a family in trouble yeah and
he's got some difficulties which are
very serious difficulties in terms of
what happened to him with abuse etc etc
but i'll tell you what
you can't do it to republicans and i say
to some of the republicans especially
the rhinos because we have some very
stupid republicans also i say don't you
sometimes have to fight fire with fire
what do you what are your plans for uh
2024 so
i love our country i think you'll be
very happy i would say this uh two three
years ago you might not have been that
happy but now i think you'd be very
happy
uh i think especially when you see
what's happening yesterday
no we're gonna i'll make a decision in
the not too distant future but i love
our country and i think a lot of people
are going to be very happy and if you
look at the poll numbers i certainly
like that because it's
we got one the other day 98 approval
rating in the republican party nobody
reagan had 87 we have a 98 approval
rating
and that makes me feel good it makes me
feel appreciated not like a guy like you
that could be critical
in the past only in the past
all right so i have to ask you do you
miss twitter at all do you would you ha
do you tweet in your head like because
you're not on there anymore well you
know a lot of people think twitter was
bad for me i disagree i think it was
good for me yeah twitter's become a very
boring place as i unders i don't want to
be like bragging or anything but people
are saying it's become very boring you
made that you made the site
you know when i went onto twitter like
12 years ago twitter was a failed
operation
and it became successful and a lot of
people said i had a lot to do with it
when they took me off i had
way over 100 million people and then if
you add facebook and everything else
it's over 200 million people that's a
lot you go from 200 million people to
nothing overnight what i do now is i
have
save america and i release things and
i'm getting tremendous play and we're
suing twitter facebook google we're
suing them all a class action suit
anybody wants to join please join feel
feel free
but we're suing them and i think it's a
great lawsuit these people are sick
you know zuckerberg
used to come you know the lock boxes
which i call the unlock boxes because
they unlock
so the unlock box is all over the place
but he used to come to the white house
to kiss my ass
and i'd say oh that's nice i have the
head of i have the head of facebook
coming with his lovely wife and they
come in that have dinner with me in the
white house
and then you see what they do about me
and about republicans and it's just sort
of crazy but that's the way the world
works uh when you are watching how the
media treats joe biden this is such an
obvious question but it's worth bringing
up there's always a game that we play on
the five it's like imagine if it's trump
if you look at the certain things that
like joe biden leaving behind
afghan afghan translators if it were you
you would be called a racist correct
because they are because they are and
they'd be impeaching me yeah we've been
teaching you for many many different and
now you have this phone call right this
phone call that he made to the afghan
president he's not asking him to lie
yeah right so
that is
that is not a perfect phone call no that
is not my call was a perfect call so how
do they how do they how does how does
the psychology of disorder how do they
square that in their head knowing what
they did before i'm talking about the
media you know my call when i heard
there was a we sent it to the justice
department these guys
i didn't know who they were there was a
certain division and they called back
and they said uh
we've read this transcript three or four
times
uh what exactly are you looking for you
know these are guys that are looking at
drug deals and all sorts of bad stuff
they're going
what is it you are looking for that they
couldn't figure it out
it was a perfect call when you watched
this call this was not a good call no
this was not a good call he was asking
him to lie in order to make it look
better maybe to make himself look better
or politically whatever but it was like
i've been calling ghani a crook for a
long time
how much money he walked away with 200
million in fact he couldn't get it all
into the helicopter they left a lot of
it on the runway do you think some
people at the airport were happy it just
kills me and you don't even have money
you don't even hear that story no you
don't and you don't hear that much about
afghanistan anymore you know i watch the
evening news
and they talk about everything they can
but they don't like to talk about
afghanistan
all right that was powerful
but you know we're going to do now we've
got to turn to an immediate post
interview with the interviewer
gene nelson reports with gene nelson
well greg let me just say i thought last
night's interview was the best thing i
had ever seen until i saw tonight's
interview hands down the best thing i've
ever witnessed you know i have to agree
with you and i did the interview uh but
you'll be surprised to learn steve that
there will be a part four later in this
show and then tomorrow a part five wow i
can't wait for that i mean it's gene
once again you were on my show yesterday
gene nelson reports steve do you work
out
uh a little bit you know i like to binge
how much do you bench uh about 250 hmm
these deal of weights well i work out
but i don't use weights i use the body
weight of my workout partner i have him
straddle me on my back and then i do
squat thrusts
you want to you want to go work out
i don't have my workout clothes you
won't need anything
here he is
guests
this former place kicker is up and he's
good fox news contributor and former gop
congressman jason timbits
this ex-public defender has taken more
prison calls than cats
former white house national security
council aide cash mattel
she likes her men tall dark and on life
support fox news contributor cat tip
and even his inner child is bigger than
most people my massive sidekick in the
nwa's world development
all right so tonight we saw joe biden uh
talking uh i did this presser on uh on
the on all these new covered
requirements it was pretty strange
pretty weird broke some really scary
ground and tyrus you made a very good
point and i wanna allow when you compare
joe biden to trump in the world of
vaccines and you saw the interview last
night when he was talking about
persuading my wife to get the vaccine
there's a noticeable contrast between
who can persuade and who can't well it
wasn't even that
what he did was is he talked as somebody
who
is a parent as a as a father and a
leader and how important it was and he
put some facts behind it but it was a
very
i guess untrump-like
response because we're always used to
the narrative where he doesn't care
about you he's very selfish but he was
giving you good reasons and at the same
time he was also respecting your wife's
decision not to do it right he's you
know and then from the other side of it
the side that's supposed to be that way
he was basically threatening us right by
by telling somebody we're losing our
patience with you yeah
that's his frustration
you hired your administration you're not
getting rid of anyone and the the worst
part the reason why that didn't get a
lot of attention was because mainstream
media's
whole narrative is that it's the
trumpers that don't get vaccinated and
if those are the ones that are hurt in
the country
the leader of the trumpers
is not only vaccinated he's promoting to
get vaccinated and he's doing in a way
to where you're comfortable with it it
wasn't he didn't insult your wife he
didn't say if i was you i'd divorce her
you know what i'm saying because that's
what
so we're seeing the the size of
what was supposed to be
you put those two interviews together
run them side by side and you look at
yourself who's the bully
and who the american people gonna listen
to
and it's gonna it's president trump
jason i when i saw biden today and i'm
like going like
he's going to re-elect trump if trump
wins
decides to run
you're exactly right i mean he was angry
he was upset he was trying to blame
everybody else and then he gives this
exception out to the postal workers
everybody who's in federal government
has to do it except the postal workers
if you really think about it who is the
per who are the people within the
federal government that you interact
with most yeah
it's the postal workers they come to
your house every day for goodness sake
you go to the counter to buy stamps and
mail things but they get a pass
it just makes no sense donald trump i
think he created the vaccine and it was
kamala harris and joe biden that were
saying oh i wouldn't do it if he was
involved
they were the they were i mean using
their criteria or his criteria
biden and kamala harris were a threat to
our public safety yeah they were a
threat to our public safety by saying
don't use the vaccines because biden
made it very clear that the
people not vaccinated the 80 million of
which he won't delineate and say who
they are are a threat to public safety
he said that he sell you a public cash
you worked at the trump administration
do you think he's going to run again
uh yeah 100 percent yeah he's going to
run again yeah that's just me and my
thoughts yeah yeah yeah
what uh what are your how do you think
it's going to go this is going to be the
craziest thing ever isn't it well i
don't know i was talking to tyres about
it before does biden stay for the full
year does kamala try to come in it's
such a political disaster that they've
created because they violated as you
guys were saying every law they put
against trump they are themselves
violating kovid afghanistan the border
what have you so i don't know that
president trump needs to do anything
if he does decide to run again in 2024
he just needs to let them keep ruining
the country unfortunately
and they'll elect they'll elect him and
put him back in office yeah cat uh
there's a last night after the interview
a left-wing blog spread
disinformation saying that we added a
laugh track to the interview when in
fact it was our audience that was
laughing they have not taken it down
msn.com
ran it people are running it
shouldn't they take that down now that
they know that they were wrong they
should but it's also isn't it kind of
the greatest compliment ever yes that's
we're so funny that people think we
can't possibly be that funny yeah we are
and i think it also shows just how in a
bubble that they are that they thought
there's no because remember when the
show first started and everyone they
were starting rumors that it was
cancelled after three days yes and now
we're beating everybody else it's like
they'll never learn
that if they don't get outside their
bubble they're not going to have any
access to everyone else out there which
is more than like five people
all right i gotta ask you
what were your feelings watching biden
as a libertarian today i mean i'm
obviously pissed off but like i'm pissed
off most of the time i hear him talk
about
who does he think he is like if you
don't own your body you don't live in a
free society that is true you cannot
apply this logic to any other thing i
mean it's insane they're going to
compare it to smallpox but i believe
that's a little bit different smallpox
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else